hola a todos cómo están soy leonor de
khan academy el día de hoy vamos a
hablar sobre mentalidad de crecimiento
estamos muy contentos que ustedes nos
acompañen porque con todos con más al
menos mucho del amor de khan academy
vamos a hablar su totalidad de nada
conozco más
a ver para ti nos podrías apoyar este es
proyectando la presentación por favor
para que podamos iniciar
claro hola a todos buenas tardes soy
para ti garcía nuevamente estoy aquí
acompañando a leonor
para platicar un poco de lo que es
mentalidad de crecimiento y de esta
serie de actividades que khan academy ha
lanzado no para nuestros estudiantes y
que realmente son una enorme oportunidad
para que nuestros alumnos en méjico
desarrollo en mente es mucho más fuertes
y mucho más adaptadas no a lo que es el
cambio y a superar las frustraciones
entonces voy a compartir con ustedes
la presentación
ok
estoy un poco lejos estoy esté en un
lugar remoto de canadá en un lugar este
muy rural entonces probablemente
tengamos algo de lentitud en internet
les pido ahora así que su paciencia
bueno entonces este es el webinar número
3 de mentalidad de crecimiento
bienvenidos todos nuevamente gracias por
su compromiso por su tiempo por su
energía espero que estén teniendo un
maravilloso regreso a clases aquí les
dejo el enlace para esta presentación
jeje punto jeje diagonal de h o de y
entonces les pido que si tienen su
dispositivo a la mano lo bajen en caso
de que de acá no lo tengan pueden tomar
una foto con su celular de este enlace
para más adelante la puedan bajar lo
puedan guardar este no en sus archivos
para referencia más adelante
puedes apuntar por favor leonor el
enlace en el chat para que la long que
se vayan yendo lo tengan siempre acceso
a ella
y vamos a mencionarles por qué estamos
haciendo esto
este curriculum se desarrolló como base
de un programa que estamos lanzando el
país y si pudieras darle si a la
siguiente es line es para que les
explique un poco de qué se trata
a verme antes que nada antes de que no
les expliqué lo que es campeonato que
muchos de ustedes ya lo conocen esta es
la agenda para el día de hoy vamos a ver
este campeonato de canacar de me lo no
nos va a contar cuáles son las últimas
noticias cómo va este este programa tan
increíble de khan academy vamos a hablar
sobre mentalidad de crecimiento que es
mentalidad de crecimiento tipo de
actividades y finalmente este daremos
también espacio para preguntas y
respuestas adelante leonor
hay muchas gracias pues bueno el
campeonato es el programa estrella de
khan academy es un programa que
desarrolló khan academy en eeuu en 2015
llamado blair néstor este programa se
desarrolló para motivar el regreso a
clases qué quiere decir motivar el
aprendizaje en el regreso a clases que
tenemos estudiantes que regresan y
tienen huecos en su aprendizaje que tal
vez no están tan motivados en llegar
otra vez al salón de clases y empezar
con el currículum del maestro y lo que
queremos es que los maestros dejen de
tener esos problemas de apatía cuando
llegan los alumnos al salón de clase y
que tengan alumnos que puedan seguir
adelante con su currículum y tengan más
confianza en ellos y lo que hicimos es
desarrollar todo un currículum
precisamente para ayudar a motivar la
confianza de los alumnos que es justo el
tema del webinar de hoy la mentalidad de
crecimiento y por otro lado la
plataforma que ya contiene en sí toda
una serie de ejercicios y contenido
curricular que va a ayudar al maestro de
matemáticas y de ciencias a mover
moverse y mover adelante a clase
entonces unos cuantos datos para que
sepan un poco cuando como donde quien
este pues cuando abrimos las
inscripciones de 13 de agosto pero
seguirán abiertas hasta que lancemos el
programa que es el 10 de septiembre
vamos a dejarlas abiertas durante el
programa porque porque queremos que
todos los profesores en la república
mexicana puedan participar cualquier
nuestro de primaria a bachillerato va a
poder inscribir a sus alumnos en este
reto y están invitados pues obviamente
todas las escuelas de méxico sin
importar su infraestructura sin importar
este el número de alumnos que tengan en
su salón de clases si tienen 25 o 35 o
40 pueden participar lo que queremos es
que
pues probamos es lo más justo y alcance
a todos otro de los temas que nos han
preguntado mucho es para aquellos que
tienen poca conectividad porque sus
infraestructura en sus escuelas es cómo
lo van a hacer no quiero que sepan que
tenemos una alianza acontece en los
usuarios de terceros pueden usar tanto
la aplicación web como la página usando
este pues una liga especial que si
quieren la podemos compartir con ustedes
para acceder a la plataforma en casos de
conectividad de baja
siguiente muchos nos han preguntado y
como participo siso del profesor pues
antes que nada y creo que es muy
importante que lo tomen en cuenta antes
de inscribirse tienen que abrir su
cuenta en khan academy y agregar una
clase en el proceso de inscripción la
misma plataforma te pregunta
si eres profesor alumno padre de familia
y tú al escoger profesor te va a
preguntar qué materias pues este dar
clase de matemáticas de química física
tecnología este y tú escoges en el grado
también pueden escoger grados y das en
primaria secundaria o bachillerato y te
va a aparecer toda una serie de materias
y
disponibles para que tú las escojas
entonces es muy importante que tú ya
tengas tu clase y tu cuenta y una vez
que hayas creado tu clase se te pedirá
que te inscribas al car and campeonato
si así lo deseas y durante el campeonato
que es este programa de 10 semanas que
inicia el 10 de septiembre y termina el
16 de noviembre lo que van a poder hacer
los profesores es usar el contenido de
la plataforma que tenemos toda una gama
de contenido disponible para que los
profesores lo asignen a sus estudiantes
que son artículos vídeos ejercicios y
está práctica la van a poder asignar a
diferentes grupos de estudiantes o
dentro de su mismo salón de clase eso se
llama práctica personalizada qué quiere
decir esto en términos generales que
tenemos alumnos que tal vez estés ya
sean muy avanzados en ciertos temas y
otros que tengan huecos en su
aprendizaje entonces lo que hace un
profesor en khan academy es asignar
práctica dentro de su materia y la puede
dividir en grupos o puede asignar a un
alumno que es lector un artículo o un
alumno que es visual pues un vídeo
entonces tienes toda una serie de
herramientas como profesor a tu
disposición para poder avanzar en tu
materia no y por otro lado está todo
este tema de celebración qué pasa cuando
un alumno hace la tarea que el profesor
le asignó pues lo que va a tener es por
su parte de una serie de medallas
premios virtuales y el profesor va a
tener un tablero de progreso que solo
tiene el profesor y lo van a poder este
ver los alumnos junto con su profesor no
en el momento en que el profesor le dé
clic al botón de checar el progreso o
revisar mi progreso en toda la clase
para poder ver cómo ha avanzado en su
totalidad entonces esto promueve que los
alumnos trabajen de manera individual
para un bien colectivo es decir para un
objetivo colectivo de la clase de cuáles
todos hacen la tarea todos avanzan
haciendo sus propios esfuerzos y pues
contribuyendo al éxito de la clase en su
totalidad
entonces como profesor pues es muy
importante que no olvides registrarte
primero en khan academy y agregar tu
clase al hacer esos dos primeros pasos
ya una vez que tengas tu cuenta en ghana
academy y a tener esta clase te
aparecerá un botón en el banner este del
panel de control del profesor que dice
inscríbete al campeonato es la página
del campeonato por si la quieren revisar
es esta se llama campeonato punto khan
academy punto o hereje y el banner se ve
de la siguiente manera si para ti nos
podrías apoyar con los siguientes
este es life sports como pueden ver hay
un botón azul que hice inscríbete al
campeonato este banner es lo que te
aparece una vez que ya te inscribiste
cuando te registraste a khan academy y
inscribirte a tu clase tenemos toda una
serie de recursos dentro de la misma
página de campeonato si eres un profesor
y no tienes por ejemplo tus alumnos
agregados no importa es muy fácil
agregar
algunos los puedes hacer a través de un
correo electrónico o sea puedes agregar
a tus alumnos dentro o agregando sus
correos electrónicos o con un código
especial que se genera cuando tú creas
tu clase
siguiente
perfecto pues hablemos un poquito del
contenido del programa que es lo que les
comentaba vayamos si quieren de manera
muy ligera esto es lo que le aparece un
profesor que por ejemplo se inscribe a
khan academy le va a aparecer las
diferentes materias que hay en
matemáticas ciencias y los grados y el
profesor este de esta manera le da le da
clic a alguno de los cuadritos y puede
ir eligiendo las diferentes materias
disponibles
ya sea por grado por materia y el
profesor puede asignar cuantos quieran
no hay límites del tema
como se dice de contenido que pueda
asignar
como pueden ver pues hay diferentes
tipos de actividades que pueden asignar
los profesores uno de ellos son
artículos los alumnos pueden artículo o
pueden por ejemplo digamos la siguiente
slide
pueden hacer ejercicios esto es un
ejemplo de un ejercicio cómo ser un
ejercicio khan academy entonces pueden
hacer cuestionarios
y el profesor va viendo se califica
automáticamente esto es una prueba de
unidad por ejemplo y entonces el
profesor puede ir viendo cómo le va a
cada alumno individualmente sin tener
que calificar
no sé si tengas algún comentario aquí
para ti
no hasta habitamos
siguiente
paralelo a este contenido curricular es
decir tú como maestro de ciencias o
matemáticas o de computación
tú vas a tener disponible todo este
material de tu materia pero está todo
este tema de desarrollar habilidades no
de cómo vamos a hacer que nuestros
alumnos además de tener pues el
conocimiento de nuestra materia sean
personas que pueden participar en un
proyecto o cuando se les presenta una
situación difícil saber superar
conocerse a sí mismos conocer el proceso
de aprendizaje por esta esta razón
desarrollamos una serie de actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento que son
unas actividades que se desarrollaron
para que los alumnos entiendan un poco
el proceso de aprendizaje porque lo que
hace el maestro en su salón de clases es
pues obviamente dar el contenido a su
materia pero qué pasa cuando el profesor
no le dan material para enseñar sobre
procesos de aprendizaje y darle a sus
alumnos estrategias
para aprender lo que hicimos es trabajar
con un centro de investigación de
stanford y desarrollar todo un
currículum que va a estar dentro del
campeonato
para que los procesos con casos de
estudio son vídeos testimoniales que
desarrollamos con una serie de
elecciones para el profesor son como
guías para los profesores para que lo
implementen en clase y toda una serie de
recursos que son muy variados y que van
a ayudar al profesor a poder implementar
una mentalidad de crecimiento que
ahorita vamos a ir de lleno a este
concepto y van a poder entender un
poquito que se trata de qué se trata
porque nos parece algo abstracto es algo
que eeuu se está empezando a usar
entonces me imagino que en mexico pues
también es algo incipiente algo que
están haciendo entonces queremos que
nuestros estudiantes en méxico pues
tengan la mejor calidad de contenido en
sus estudios tengan todas las
oportunidades y obviamente pues
desarrollen todas sus habilidades
entonces para que tienen un poquito
desarrollamos un curriculum que está
dividido en primaria y secundaria es
educación básica y por otro lado en
sobre toda mentalidad de crecimiento
para que entiendan un poquito de este
currículum de las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento y otro
currículum para los alumnos de
bachillerato en ellos incluimos
testimonios de estudiantes y vídeos para
que entiendan cómo funciona su cerebro y
cómo el cerebro es como un como si fuera
un músculo que crece y cuando lo
ejercitamos x se vuelve más fuerte y
cuando lo probamos se vuelve más fuerte
no entonces lo que nos dimos cuenta es
que no podríamos crear un currículum
para todos no igual no le puedes hablar
a un niño de primaria de la misma manera
que le hablas un adolescente que está a
punto o un joven que está a punto de
entrar a la universidad entonces
obviamente desarrollamos el currículum
pensando en estas diferencias de edades
y basados en testimonios de personas de
esos rangos de edad no
y bueno vamos a dar pie grandes adriana
por no poder explicar esta parte del
campeonato tan importante ya que estamos
a nada no a días de comenzar ya con
campeonato
recuerde que ya las inscripciones están
abiertas es el 13 de agosto recuerden
también que antes de que se inscriban es
súper súper importante que eliminen las
clases que ya que ya tienen y que no
están usando osa clases del año pasado
que ya son clases muertas clases que ya
no utilizan
recuerden eliminarlas antes de
inscribirse porque en el momento que se
inscriban automáticamente todas las
clases que han creado que tienen en khan
academy quedarán inscritas en campeonato
es por eso que es muy importante que se
den a la tarea unos minutos
para eliminar sus cuentas antiguas no
sus cuentas perdón sus clases antiguas y
bueno vamos a hablar ahora de lo que es
mentalidad de crecimiento y yo creo que
lo primero es preguntarnos qué es
mentalidad de crecimiento yo creo que
para algunos de nosotros este término
es nuevo no lo conocemos no estamos
familiarizados y bueno la mentalidad
crecimiento es la cree es esta creencia
de que realmente podemos enfrentar los
retos no de una manera inteligente y que
nuestro cerebro se va a formando no se
va formando y va creciendo y se va
haciendo más fuerte para superar todo lo
que son a veces lo representan a veces
frustraciones frustraciones cuando
cometemos un error o cuando no
entendemos algo etcétera no a la vez que
estas mentes fuertes van creando
habilidades estrategias para el
aprendizaje la mentalidad de crecimiento
se centra básicamente en el proceso del
aprendizaje no tanto en el resultado de
si lo tuve bien o lo tuve mal sino que
aprendí en el proceso y convertir estos
retos cometer estas situaciones
difíciles estas situaciones en donde
cometemos un error convertirlos en un
éxito en una victoria sacar provecho
errores y convertirlos en una lección en
un aprendizaje y que viene siendo la
mentalidad fija no la mentalidad fija y
la creencia de que es realmente nuestro
cerebro pues es loco con lo que nacemos
y no lo podemos desarrollar y es como
quien dice lo que los topo no y muchos
jóvenes en nuestras aulas tienen esta
mentalidad pues es que yo no soy bueno
para matemáticas pues es que yo no nací
para ciencias es que a mí la cabeza no
me da para esta materia y realmente
tienen esta mentalidad fija de pensar
que ellos nacieron así y que nunca
conseguirán ser exitosos en matemáticas
en ciencias o en otras materias no
entonces esta mentalidad fija se se basa
en dos cosas o se fija únicamente en dos
cosas es si tienen éxito o sí o sí o si
tienen un fracaso no entonces no hay no
hay digamos grises es blanco o negro no
cuando sin embargo en el proceso de
aprendizaje sabemos que hay muchos
grises no que a lo mejor hoy
y esto pero mañana si lo entiendo y a
medida que practique ya medida que
desarrolle mi cerebro y a medida que
vaya creyendo y yo más en mí estos
grises se van convirtiendo en más
blancos no entonces no es cuestión de
soy o no soy soy bueno o no soy bueno si
no es en trabajar para que nuestro
cerebro vaya desarrollando habilidades
tanto para superar los fracasos como
para aprender de una mejor manera no les
vamos a dejar aquí este vídeo que me
parece verdaderamente increíble
vamos se los va a poner
pero en un segundo porque es pista
o no
ahí
a ver si quiere desde acá verdad
uy perdón obviamente es que no quiere no
quiere no sabe si es por internet pero
bueno
déjenme
tú lo tienes adrián a
por qué no
vamos a ver acá
voy a poner aquí a ver si me lo da
ok
vamos a ponerlo desde acá a ver si entra
mejor porque como les digo internet
s
están viendo a mi pantalla de anna
a estos 200 años había un 15% de índice
de alfabetización y me imagino que si
pudieras preguntarle a alguien que si
pudiera leer en ese entonces qué
porcentaje de la población crees que
sabe leer hubiera dicho tal vez un 20 o
25 por ciento y ahora te adelantas 400
años y ves que es una estimación muy
pesimista de hecho un 99.99 por ciento
de la población sabe leer entonces qué
limitaciones similares tenemos hoy en
día estoy emocionado de tener aquí a
carol dweck una de mis heroínas
personales y alguien que ha influido
mucho el trabajo de khan academy carol
un placer tenerte aquí es un gusto estar
aquí sí me gustaría empezar con este
concepto de mentalidad de crecimiento
que tengo entendido que tú inventaste
cuando se te ocurrió cuál fue la
motivación y qué es una mentalidad de
crecer
es cuando el estudiante cree que sus
habilidades pueden desarrollarse una
mentalidad fija es cuando piensan solo
tengo una cierta habilidad y eso es todo
y esto no es solo por sentirse bien está
basado en la ciencia que en realidad del
cerebro si se fortalece se crean nuevas
conexiones neuronales cuando hay un
esfuerzo estudio tras estudio hemos
demostrado que los niños que tienen una
mentalidad de crecimiento obtienen
mejores calificaciones no es una
elección entre el resultado y la
mentalidad demuestran que si los niños
se involucra en profunda y
emocionalmente en el proceso de
aprendizaje las calificaciones y los
resultados son un producto que se da por
sí solo los niños a los que les
reconocen su inteligencia según nuestros
estudios no quieren un reto después no
quieren trabajar duro en algo y si
tienen dificultades lo dejan
hemos visto que si nosotros o los padres
reconocen el proceso en el que está el
niño su trabajo duro pero no sólo eso
sus estrategias sus ideas su
concentración su persistencia
entonces el alumno aprende que estos son
los ingredientes del éxito si se pone
difícil solo tengo que hacer estas cosas
ya hemos trabajado contigo introduciendo
e ideas de mentalidad de crecimiento
para los problemas matemáticos y hemos
descubierto que los chicos aprenden
mejor lo que yo espero es que la gente
que nuestros vídeos vayan y le digan a
sus padres a sus hijos compañeros
maestros alumnos sobre la mentalidad de
crecimiento que el cerebro crece cuando
cometen un error cuando se esfuerzan
cuando ven sus errores y dicen eso es
interesante no tienes por qué
avergonzarte de tus errores debes verlo
como algo interesante que hay que
explorar cuando haces eso de verdad vas
a formar conexiones neuronales
tu cerebro crecerá
era negativa no sé si quieres comenzar a
comentar algo de este vídeo
leonor mira para todos los que viendo
seguramente este se estén preguntando
por quién es esta persona quien es carol
dweck éste quien en dónde está este
centro de investigación académica de
stanford quienes son y se están haciendo
muchas preguntas no caros web para que
tengan un poco de contexto es una
psicóloga y profesora de la universidad
de stanford y ya ha hecho toda una serie
de investigación que que va desde la
psicología del desarrollo psicología
social psicología de la personalidad y
ella en lo que se ha enfocado es en los
conceptos de identidad propia y cómo
estructuramos esa identidad y la usamos
o no
guiamos esa identidad en nuestro
comportamiento entonces ella es una
psicóloga que tiene un largo camino este
es una persona muy reconocida
ha hecho toda su investigación en torno
a la mentalidad de crecimiento ella
acuñó se terminó ya lo inventó y es
gracias a ella que tenemos pues toda
esta serie de investigaciones que se han
hecho acerca de nuestro cerebro y cómo
funciona cuando estamos aprendiendo
entonces para que sepan un poquito el
contexto de dónde sale este término pues
lo inventa esta investigadora de
stanford y es gracias a ella y todo su
trabajo que ha ganado además de muchos
premios pues ha ganado mucho
financiamiento para estudiar el cerebro
y es gracias a ella que se funda parks
que va a ser un centro de investigación
stanford que se llama proyecto para la
investigación académica escala y este
centro si quieres puedes darle
el siguiente partido para que encuentro
para que ver un poquito tienes que
sports y quien es dave dave es el
director de parks de este proyecto de
investigación académica y lo que hacen
en este centro es investigar el
rendimiento académico no como pensar en
darle a los estudiantes estrategias
efectivas para alcanzar su potencial es
lo que se dieron cuenta que este sobre
todas las comunidades que tienen pocos
recursos y los estudiantes que vienen de
comunidades que tienen pocos recursos
tienen muy bueno bajas calificaciones y
menos oportunidades de lograr el éxito y
lo que queremos es que esos este abismos
socioeconómicos y esas desigualdades
desaparezcan y todos los podemos lograr
si hay estrategias eficientes para esos
alumnos que más lo necesitan entonces lo
que está haciendo este centro este este
proyecto
investigación académica pues es
precisamente darle a los profesores
estrategias efectivas para que sus
alumnos puedan lograr alcanzar su
potencial
y lo que es todo lo que hicimos con dave
aquí en khan academy es trabajar con él
para armar este currículum de sangre
hable anteriormente y este pues
presentárselos a ustedes no estamos muy
contentos de lanzarlo por primera vez en
méxico sentimos que es algo que va a
impactar mucho y que va a ayudar a
nuestros jóvenes en méxico
les voy a poner este el vídeo de dave
que en cuanto a que es información muy
importante que realmente nos puede
aportar mucho como maestros y también
para que entendamos un poco más de qué
es lo que khan academy está haciendo
cuál es la razón por la que lo está
haciendo en que está trabajando voy a
poner los subtítulos para que lo podamos
entender de una mejor manera
antes
y
de gran caribe de radio the guild wars
de talleres amateur lights game and
antiquities rolling
entonces como ven no son son actividades
que no tienen necesariamente que ver con
matemáticas ni con ciencias son
actividades que simplemente van a
enseñar a nuestros alumnos
a tener diferentes estrategias a saber
qué hacer cuando no entienden algo
cuando se se enfrentan a una dificultad
y yo creo que esto es importante no
solamente en nuestras clases de
matemáticas y ciencias yo creo que esto
es un recurso importantísimo para la
vida para enseñarlos no a enfrentar
frustraciones enfrentar fracasos y que
sigan adelante hasta lograr el éxito
khan academy como les comentamos ya
trabajo muy de cerca complex el centro
de investigación de la universidad de
stanford que con el objetivo de darle a
los educadores herramientas y
estrategias lo que están basadas en
evidencia y en estudios para ayudar a
sus alumnos a alcanzar la excelencia y
el éxito dentro de la escuela y
nuevamente también en su vida
profesional
algunas ideas erróneas sobre mentalidad
de crecimiento como lo comentaba en el
vídeo muchos de nuestros alumnos piensan
que así nacieron así como como lo
comentaré que así como tenemos los ojos
azules o verdes o cafés o negros que así
es su cerebro no ya no lo pueden cambiar
así nacieron y eso es lo que tienen y
está esta idea esta forma de pensar es
totalmente errónea porque es cierto es
como un músculo el cerebro es un músculo
que a medida que lo usamos que lo
trabajamos que lo desarrolló hoy se va
haciendo más fuerte mentalidad de
crecimiento es trabajar duro tener altas
expectativas tener residencias o ideas
generales cómo ser abierto flexible no
entras estás si están asociadas en este
proceso no la gente
los alumnos que completan estas
actividades van van creando más
resistencia digamos al fracaso se van
volviendo más perseverantes y además
también más aceptan más los retos no
también digo yo como docente de
matemáticas y de ciencias les he contado
que bueno antes de trabajar para
detective o phil maestra de matemáticas
y ciencias por 15 años en con alumnos de
secundaria y yo creo que algo que a mí
me sorprendía mucho es que los alumnos
cuando se enfrentan a algo difícil a un
reto automáticamente sin siquiera
intentarlo ya se dan por vencidos no
esto es no yo no puedo con eso no yo no
voy a poder con esto nuestro está muy
difícil los antes de poder trabajar con
eso ya están sintiéndose fracasados y yo
creo que de eso se trata este este
programa de cambiarles ese switch que
tienen con respecto a materias como
matemáticas y ciencias si tienen una
mentalidad de crecimiento o no pueden
aprender lo que sea y yo creo que esto
es
totalmente cierto no es como como un
chico que es bueno en deportes
y cuando sabe que es bueno y cuando
tiene confianza en sí mismo y dice me
pueden poner con quien sea que yo voy a
ganarlo porque confía en él porque sabe
de sus aptitudes porque sabe de sus
fortalezas lo mismo es con una cuando
tenemos una mentalidad fuerte una
mentalidad de crecimiento hoy por hoy
vamos a quiero hacer una pausa para que
comentar algo con respecto a lo que
estabas diciendo y es muy interesante y
es que nuestra cultura está está basada
o orientada hacia el éxito y pocas veces
hablamos del fracaso como este
o sea tanto nuestros padres como
nuestros maestros pues obviamente
quieren que tengamos buenas
calificaciones pero qué pasa cuando un
alumno no logra tener buenas
calificaciones qué pasa cuando un alumno
entiende qué pasa cuando fracasa y
fracasa y eso es eso es un gran tema no
porque pues nuestra cultura y como nos
han enseñado es que
el fracaso es lo que tienes que evitar
el fracaso es lo peor que te puede pasar
te equivocas te está estás mal entonces
eso genera toda una serie de activo de
actitud y mentalidad que solo te lleva
en un círculo vicioso que no te permite
seguir adelante entonces cuando tú
tienes una mentalidad de crecimiento
consideras el fracaso no como un fracaso
total sino como un área de oportunidad
para seguir adelante y eso es justo lo
que queremos decir aquí que hasta ese
estudiante que es brillantísimo tiene
áreas de oportunidad y tiene área de
crecer de llegar a alcanzar su potencial
una de las cosas o errores que hacemos
mucho como padres de familia o como
profesores es premiar a los estudiantes
más brillantes cuando tú le dices a un
estudiante brillante eres brillantísimos
y así le estás el mensaje que le estás
dando es que no se tiene que esforzar
más cuando él tal vez tienes la
oportunidad 90 lento de ir
más lejos
y eso es algo que dice carol dweck
también
ok me escucharan
si para ti te escuchamos
o sea no más un otro punto que quiero
que entiendan un poco los profesores
aquí es que la mentalidad de crecimiento
lo que busca es cultivar habilidades no
quiere decir que no existan personas
talentosas o no existan personas que
tienen habilidades que se desarrollan
naturalmente no es sólo que eso lo que
dice la mentalidad de crecimiento la
mentalidad de crecimiento lo que quiere
decir es que a pesar de que hay gente
que empieza o tiene diferentes niveles
tal vez de estudios o de habilidades las
habilidades se desarrollan es algo que
tu cerebro tu cerebro puede hacer y
puede crecer y puede mejorar y aunque no
eras bueno antes puedes ser bueno y a
través de tu esfuerzo a través de tus
fracasos tú encuentras y tienes las
herramientas son las estrategias
correctas para llegar al éxito
algo también aquí importante que yo
quiero comentar es lo que vienen siendo
los reconocimientos y esto bueno si si
somos papás si alguno de ustedes sea
padre de familia lo sabemos no cuando
nosotros premiamos a nuestros hijos
etcétera sin que realmente hayan logrado
no algo positivo o no se les damos una
retroalimentación positiva de algo que
realmente no está bien hecho realmente
estamos dañando los no hay muchas veces
tendemos a hacer eso como padres de
familia pero también como maestros
y dar algún reconocimiento a algún
alumno cuando sabemos que no dio su 100%
o que lo que hizo no está del todo bien
o no puso su mayor esfuerzo etcétera y
esto lejos de ayudarlos lejos de
motivarlos etcétera les estamos haciendo
un daño no entonces es importante que
nosotros siempre estamos motivando a
nuestros alumnos pero que también lo
sabemos y lo reconozcamos cuando
realmente tengan los resultados que se
están esperando lo que ellos mismos
esperan no esta parte es muy importante
porque si no pueden obtener el mensaje
equivocado
porque mentalidad de crecimiento
entonces
claramente digo los alumnos que tienen
una mentalidad de crecimiento fuerte que
tienen una mente digamos sólida y
resistente etcétera tienen niveles de
éxito más alto que aquellos que tienen
una mentalidad fija entonces cuando
nosotros le enseñamos a nuestros alumnos
acerca de estas actividades les pedimos
que resuelvan estas actividades etcétera
ellos van poco a poco confiando más en
sí mismos siendo más positivos respecto
a sus habilidades a sus capacidades y se
van volviendo a la vez más perseverantes
y más exitosos en khan academy la idea
es reforzar estas mentes al
decrecimiento de diversas maneras y hay
diferentes tipos de tipos de actividades
no que se utilizan en khan academy para
fortalecer las mentes de nuestros
alumnos no vamos tenemos varias
actividades no que la idea
que los alumnos conozcan cuál es la
verdad sobre su cerebro no cómo pueden
desarrollarlo cuáles son las mejores
estrategias de aprendizaje para ellos
etcétera qué voz es la que van a elegir
escuchar la del yo no puedo eres un
fracasado tú no sabes hacer esto o al
contrario no la voz de yo puedo yo tengo
que lograrlo si me esfuerzo lo logro no
siguiendo las estrategias adecuadas lo
puedo conseguir etcétera entonces la
idea es convertir estos errores o estos
fracasos en oportunidades y también
tenemos actividades con el objetivo de
que los alumnos aprendan a superar los
retos a superar la frustración y que
realmente cambien su mentalidad para
poder enfocarse en lo que es el futuro y
no quedarse atorado y atrapado en los
fracasos del presente o del pasado
y qué debo hacer como docente para
promover una mentalidad de crecimiento
en mis alumnos durante el campeonato
ustedes van a tener la posibilidad de
asignar semanalmente a sus alumnos
estas actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento entonces semanalmente vamos
a asignar las a todos nuestros alumnos
para que ellos las las completen como
les comenté hace rato no son actividades
de matemáticas ni de ciencias ni nada
por el estilo y la idea también es ser
empáticos con nuestros alumnos yo creo
que para los alumnos es muy importante
entender que nosotros como docentes no
somos perfectos que también hemos
cometido errores que también fallamos
que también tenemos fracasos pero que el
punto lo importante es ser perseverantes
hasta lograr el éxito no y yo siempre
les cuento a mis alumnos no que yo daba
clases de matemáticas en secundaria sin
embargo les contaba que yo cuando estaba
en primaria era
hasta matemáticas hasta que llegue con
un maestro que realmente le dio el giro
no me supo motivarme es como tener
paciencia etcétera y las matemáticas se
convirtieron en materia de preferencia
en lo que más me gustó no entonces y de
ahí me animé a estudiar química y es no
ya ya ser científica etcétera pero bastó
que un profesor creyera en mí basta que
un profesor me hiciera ver que yo no era
mala mala para algo no entonces es muy
importante compartir también nuestras
experiencias como docentes con los
alumnos para que se den cuenta ellos
también que siempre existe otro camino y
siempre existe la posibilidad de vernos
a nosotros mismos de otra manera
les los queremos invitar a que compartan
con nosotros sus historias de mentalidad
de crecimiento pueden usar en twitter el
hashtag campeonato 2018 pueden usarlo
también en facebook en cualquier red
social que ustedes utilicen por favor
compartan con nosotros fotos vídeos
experiencias alegrías fracasos etcétera
nos situaciones de conflictos
situaciones exitosas yo creo que para
todos toda la comunidad de docentes en
nuestro país es importante conocerlas no
entonces los invitamos a que a que las
hagan públicas a que las compartan con
todos los maestros con nosotros
utilizando nuevamente este hashtag a
campeonato 2018 tanto en facebook como
en instagram como en twitter como un
link en la red en la que ustedes usen o
si usan todas pues en todas los vamos a
agradecer mucho
por ejemplo en eeuu lo que nos
compartieron para ti y todos los que nos
están escuchando también han dibujos por
currículum de primaria les pedían que se
dibujarán como persiguen su cerebro
antes y después entonces un niño dibujo
su cerebro con una planta y entre más la
regaba pues más este plante como
plantitas crecían y está muy curioso
porque eso lo hicieron totalmente los
alumnos el profesor no no les dijo nada
jamás existe pues les compartió esas
estrategias y ellos mismos quedaron toda
una serie de dibujos y material muy
interesante entonces pero que si
comparten con nosotros lo que hacen los
estudiantes aquí en méxico va a ser muy
buen muy padre
exacto
y bueno el siguiente tema es qué tipo de
actividades no vamos a ver un poco de
estas actividades no cuáles son las
actividades que los alumnos están
desarrollando aquí tenemos un ejemplo no
tenemos actividades aquí de primaria y
secundaria que son nuestras actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento no por
ejemplo actividad 1 la verdad acerca de
tu cerebro
mentalidad crecimiento etcétera si le
hacen clic aquí en el arriba en el
título nos va a llevar a lo que es a las
actividades de aumentar el crecimiento
dentro de la plataforma para que puedan
tener una visión mucho más clara
entonces aquí ya estoy entrando de lleno
a la plataforma
vamos a esperar a que se cargue unos
minutitos por favor
y bueno aquí tenemos las actividades
nosotros tenemos se divide en dos no
tenemos divididas nuestras actividades
en actividades para primaria y
secundaria y actividades de bachillerato
entonces en las actividades de primaria
y secundaria son las que están aquí en
la parte superior tenemos por ejemplo la
actividad 1 y dentro de la actividad 1
hay varias actividades no la verdad
acerca de tu cerebro entonces por
ejemplo tenemos la actividad no parte 1
ok en donde el alumno va a tener que ir
resolviendo cada una de estas partes
para completar la actividad a 1
vamos a ver si se carga sí no
vamos a ver
si es más rápido entonces los alumnos a
medida que ustedes van asignando estas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
los alumnos tienen que ir resolviéndolas
como si resolverán cualquier ejercicio
de khan academy lo la completan y la
envían o entonces
en este caso sí es importante que sigan
un orden cronológico porque tiene una
secuencia entonces por ejemplo en
algunas y otro contenido de khan academy
un profesor de matemáticas por poner
ejercicios de fracciones después
saltarse algo más
y no sea una parábola o algo así que o
que utilicen algo con fracciones pero
aquí sí cabe recalcar que es importante
que siga en el orden cronológico porque
porque un cuando terminas de realizar
una de las actividades entendiste algo
que te va a ayudar para seguir con las
demás actividades nada más era un punto
y creo que es importante que lo sepan
los profesores cuando vayan asignando a
las actividades y si se fijan por
ejemplo en el caso de primaria y
secundaria tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 7 18 19 20 actividades
lo que significa que para completar
todas dentro de las 10 semanas que dura
campeonato habría que asignar dos
actividades por semana de mentalidad de
crecimiento para que al final al
finalizar campeonato hayan podido
completar todas las actividades esto en
el caso de que estén en primaria o
secundaria no entonces es importante
considerar esto no para que no se cargue
mucho el trabajo en la semana asignar
nuestros tres recursos esté ya sean
vídeos ejercicios etcétera y sus dos
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
en la parte inferior acá tenemos
recursos para maestros ustedes aquí
pueden encontrar es un resumen consejos
útiles de qué hacer cómo asignar
etcétera
tienen también a plan de elecciones cómo
pueden dividir sus lecciones cómo pueden
ir las asignado recuerden muy bien el
consejo que le saca decir a adriana de
seguir el orden cronológico entonces
iremos asignando la primera semana
actividad 1 parte una actividad 1 parte
2 y así sucesivamente hasta que
completemos todas las actividades de lo
que es mental y de crecimiento para
primaria y secundaria no aquí están
todas las lecciones actividad 1
la verdad es traer a tu cerebro la
mentalidad de crecimiento los errores
como piezas de un rompecabezas seguir
adelante seguir creciendo potenciar tu
crecimiento potenciar tus objetivos
el camino hacia adelante
por otro lado tenemos también
luego el sar acá
lo que son las actividades de
bachillerato entonces acá tenemos
también tenemos actividad a1 y tenemos
aquí no dividido en digamos
8 diferentes actividades no en total
dentro de cada actividad tenemos también
actividad 1 parte 1 actividad diferentes
partes para completar nuevamente sigan
el orden en el caso también de
bachillerato tenemos 1 2 3 6 9 12 15 18
21 23 lecciones de mentalidad de
crecimiento para bachillerato entonces
es importante que consideren esto para
asignarlas de la mejor manera posible no
a lo mejor en alguno en algunas semanas
les tendremos que asignar tres
actividades para que al final del
campeonato hayan cubierto todas las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
nuevamente maestros de bachillerato aquí
tienen un resumen consejos útiles un
plan de acción para sus lecciones
etcétera y nuevamente aquí tenemos
también cuáles son las lecciones no
verdad hacer que tu cerebro en
mentalidad de crecimiento los errores
son oportunidades
seguir adelante seguir creciendo
potenciar tus objetivos lo que me parece
genial serendipia el camino hacia
adelante entonces creamos que todas
estas actividades actividades están
creadas pensando en beneficiar al
estudiante beneficiará al alumno que
realmente disfrute de lo que es el
proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje y
aprenda de una mejor manera algo que
quieras comentar
adrián a
y bueno como último como última parte de
este webinar tenemos cómo podemos
promover en mentalidades fuertes
entonces
testimoniales y contestando a las
preguntas de los profes y se me fue el
chat pero si si quería decir algo a
todos aquellos que ya estén dentro de
khan academy y sean profesores y ya usan
khan academy probablemente ahorita no
encuentren el contenido de mi totalidad
de crecimiento algo que vamos publicar
con el lanzamiento del programa que ese
día es de septiembre entonces todos
aquellos que nos están escuchando y
estén profesores y digan bueno pero en
donde está su contenido no se preocupen
lo van a encontrar dentro de la
plataforma de contenido de khan academy
entonces no no entren en pánico este
contenido va a estar disponible no se
preocupe este para eso vamos a compartir
con ustedes el plan de estudios que para
ti puso ahí este les podemos compartir
vean cómo va a estar organizado el
currículum y las actividades pero no se
preocupen si va a estar disponible lo
que pasa es que lo vamos a publicar el
10 de septiembre
exacto aquí también pueden descargar en
esta diapositiva en la número 31 el plan
de estudios de mentalidad de crecimiento
con que hagan clic en el enlace
automáticamente van a entrar al plan de
estudios y lo pueden descargar no este
es el resumen de las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento es un
documento en drive así ustedes utilizan
atrás lo pueden únicamente hacer clic en
archivo y agregar a su drive para que lo
tengan para futuras referencias etcétera
tenemos preguntas de honor
déjame ver
si nos preguntan que si ya se han
aplicado antes estas actividades si como
comentaba el este programa es el
programa del regreso a clases de khan
academy en eeuu y estas actividades se
desarrollaron el año pasado
con este mismo centro de investigación
de stanford y se les hizo una encuesta a
los estudiantes antes y después de hacer
las actividades y se dieron cuenta que
hay un cambio de percepción o de actitud
en la manera en la que los estudiantes
se perciben a sí mismos y estudian
entonces hay un cambio en el nivel de
confianza de los estudiantes y de los
encuestados los estudiantes que
encuestaron para bueno que participaron
en estas actividades dijeron que las
volverían a hacer y les sirvió muchísimo
para entender que su cerebro o la
inteligencia no es algo fijo no no es
algo con lo que naces no eres un genio
no es que estamos
viendo cuando estamos investigando este
término de mentalidad de crecimiento es
que las personas más brillantes de la
historia como einstein darwin y otros
científicos
no se consideraban a sí mismos como
genios ni más inteligentes que otras
personas eso es un poco el punto que
estaba diciendo antes cuando tenemos un
estudiante muy talentoso o un hijo que
es muy brillante le decimos que está
perfecto que ellos estén que ellos están
perfectos así que sigan así
no les estamos apoyando que alcancen su
potencial entonces para que entiendan un
poco es muy importante poner en práctica
este tipo de actividades para mejorar la
confianza en nuestros alumnos y que
implementen estrategias porque no sólo
basta con decir si puedo y voy a hacer
una y otra vez los ejercicios no basta
con eso no basta con tener una actitud
positiva se requieren estrategias y
estas estrategias las desarrollamos con
gente que se dedica a investigar el
rendimiento académico
excelente
y alguna otra pregunta comentario
ok pues si no hay más preguntas por
nuestra parte es todo les queremos
agradecer nuevamente su participación su
tiempo su energía su compromiso para
comenzar con el pie derecho este ciclo
escolar
gracias a leonor por tu participación y
bueno queremos invitarlos a todos a que
si no se han registrado en campeonato lo
hagan lo hagan ya lo hagan lo más pronto
posible no dejen pasar esta enorme
oportunidad para poder trabajar
con sus alumnos de manera más cerca y
además pienso que es una excelente
manera para crear un vínculo desde con
sus alumnos desde los primeros días de
clases no el trabajar en conjunto el
trabajar por un logro en común por un
objetivo en común siempre nos une
entonces es una excelente oportunidad
para motivar a nuestros alumnos para
engancharlos en nuestras clases
y reconocerlos no y para empezar como
les digo el año escolar con el pie
derecho gracias al honor por por todo
por tu participación no gracias a ti y a
todos los que nos vieron el día de hoy
estamos o sea me cabe recalcar que estas
actividades son paralelas al contenido
si es un profesor de matemáticas y tal
vez no los quieres usar no pasa nada
pero sí es importante que las apliquen
porque es parte del programa que
escribes en el programa estás haciendo
de manera transversal desarrollando
habilidades y este el conocimiento de tu
materia no entonces queremos que con la
nueva implementación del modelo
curricular esto va a ser muy interesante
y muy importante para todos los
profesores que están implementando el
nuevo modelo curricular en sus aulas
muchas gracias a todos y un gran saludo
ojalá les sirvan muchísimo estamos muy
emocionados
hasta luego bye bye hasta luego gracias
buena tarde